over which interval does y of X have an
average rate of change of negative 4 so
average rate of change if you think
about your literally just averaging for
example in this bowl section right over
here the slope is really really steep it
gets less deep it's a very negative
slope it gets less negative less
negative slope is zero here then it gets
positive more positive and more positive
and more positive but when you get to
this point right over here you see you
got to where you started from
and the average one you could say the
average the change the net change has
been zero and any interval over which
the net change has been zero also tells
you that the average rate of change is
going to be zero so you could view that
the average rate of change is really the
slope of the line is really the slope of
the line that connects the two endpoints
of your interval so another way of
asking over watch interval does yfx have
an average rate of change of negative 4
is can you come up with an interval
where the slope between the endpoints of
the interval is negative 4 so let's see
the choices they give us this first
interval is X is between negative 1 & 1
so X is between negative 1 so this is X
is negative 1 when X is equal to
negative 1 y of X is all the way over
here Y of negative 1 is equal to 7 and
then when X is equal to 1 when X is
equal to 1 our graph is down over here Y
of 1 is negative 1
so what is the slope of the line that
connects the endpoints of those two of
those two points so what is the slope of
this line because the slope of this line
the line that connects the endpoints of
my interval that is going to be the
average rate of change over this
interval and you see very clearly that
the slope here the rate of change of Y
with respect to X is negative 4 every
time we move one ahead in the X
direction we move down 4 in the Y
direction move 1 ahead in the x
direction we move down 4 in the Y
direction so the average rate of change
over this interval is negative 4 so we
didn't have to look at anything else
that one will work